[Music]
and here we are on overtime and Dexter
Filkins has joined us I understand you
and rich are in Iraq together he we were
I Dexter has been there for years I was
I had a cup of coffee but I want to talk
about Dexter and his and the things that
he does and people like him do if you've
read his book and I I wish everybody
would read it but he is the one of the
bravest people I've ever met
yeah I've said this before even if you
took away the danger level just the
discomfort level you know just the sand
in your ass with the heat and the food
when like just the day-to-day but as
someone once said don't pity the martyr
he likes his job right it's a little
like The Hurt Locker right you get home
and it's just boring you're a bit of a
junky for it aren't you Dexter
all those brands of cereal okay we were
gonna talk and we ran out of time about
Sol Andrea
Oh Sol Andra that is the that is the
solar power company that the Obama
administration fast-tracked stimulus
money - and it turns out they went
belly-up and lost five hundred million
dollars million not billion of taxpayer
money how big of a scandal is this
really because of the way it was
structured apparently these guys who
went belly-up will get the opportunity
to protect their other assets or he get
bailout money earlier whatever it is
they were moved up in the process for
the funding and also and I believe in in
their financial recovery from this from
the collapse of the company if that's
found to be it done intentionally with
any foreknowledge that there might be a
collapse then it could be a problem
otherwise it's a bad investment
apparently they made these solar panels
without silicone is that it and then the
prices dropped and they didn't I mean
they went out of business is the reason
why companies go out of business
business in a capitalistic country
that's right because somebody did it
better yeah well in this case happens to
be the Chinese unfortunately but they
but right so go back to it you know we
need to call Sarah Palin yeah the
I'll wait you can the the issue here
though bill was that a that the the
question is was there what's called a
continuing continuing business Larry
that's not they with whether the
accountants had already said we have
doubts of this going concern that this
can continue as a going concern before
all all these this money got transferred
and all these guarantee I mean it was a
it's not it's not good it's ugly it's
the whole solar in alternative energy
think definitely should never try
anything again that's my fear is that
now from now on it's just a big I role
on the right when you say green energy
or solar energy they're just gonna go uh
well Solyndra you know what happened
there yeah good thing nobody can
pronounce it right and also like no oil
companies never had a weird thing
happened right all right this is for
Keith Oberman do you ever feel that GE
restricted the journalistic freedom of
pundits on MSNBC unfortunately I'm not
allowed to say no no actually I don't
know I don't think we know wasn't that
wasn't what no no no gambling debts was
mostly my gambling debts are you happier
where you are because I you know people
still to me ten years after I mean
tomorrow is the anniversary of the what
we call around here the the tragic
events of nine seventeen when I said the
things that got me fired off of ABC but
I found I found greater happiness here
in the in the lily fields of HBO are you
do you feel well yeah but there's a
balance to it which is unfortunate
because now I'm I mean I'm in charge of
the operation so my life is a living
hell I mean I just by beat by dint of
being in charge of it really yeah you're
gonna to do think right you have to know
the names of the people in the staff
that is that was a joke all right thank
you do you think candidates would act
differently at debates if there was no
audience oh yeah it would be a
completely different experience the last
time
reporters were actually in the audience
was the debate between Dan Quayle and
Lloyd Bentsen that you're no Jack
Kennedy debates are and that and because
they're and the reason is reporters in
the hall thought that Quayle had done
quite well they thought he had done fine
hadn't thrown up on his shoes he'd think
he knew his about I mean and in the
suite afterwards wale felt really good
but on TV it was such a different
experience that now when you go what are
these debates they have these enormous
tent with TVs everywhere because
reporters want to see it the way that
home people at home see it and I think
that's right I think leaving the
audience's out would be just fine I
think with everybody leaving the debates
that would be okay I mean the crowd
brings something out in a person yeah
and they are suppresses I've seen many
times people say backstage you know we
think they're gonna be the conservative
they come out here and suddenly they're
very liberal you know that the crowd can
be very intimidating their Witnesses do
not you're not just your thoughts in
your own little private way another blue
you'd other no brains in the room had
changed everything I mean I do stand-up
so I work for crowds all the time and I
couldn't do it without a crowd I
literally couldn't really do it so how
would the brains issue apply to a
Republican well because they're Brawl
those but I mean they're running for
president and it's a popular vote so I
think they should have to stand in front
of people and say stuff amazed at how
intimidating a crowd can be considering
that you must know somewhere in your
brain left or right side that they're
not really gonna come over here and beat
you if they disagree with you the worst
that's gonna happen is ooh boo yeah
which is why I really admire people who
say things that get them booed it's good
to disagree it's good to be able to
disagree and sometimes the majority is
wrong you know just what's wrong with
just [ __ ] you this is my opinion okay
with you I mean the Nixon Kennedy thing
worked pretty well without a crowd
I mean it was just two guys two podiums
to camera or three cameras and that was
it we got away you watch it with the
sound only then you really got the
effect yes the politicians have to know
who to pander to that is their lodestar
it's very hard but you take that
audience away and I think you know they
kind of don't know where to go because
they really only why you know when you
see these people and I agree it wasn't
everybody cheering but you know that's
the the mood of that part of the right
wing right now it very mean you can't be
tough enough and you know it's gotten
that mean again all right last question
I heard the other day Larry Harwell says
that one out of five or perhaps six
Americans it's one out of six Larry live
below the poverty line worst poverty
knows we've had since ever right
houghton they tried started to keep
score how did this come to be in what
needs to be done to fix it also by the
way 22% of children oh no it's all
children of children 30 or below the
problem it's the 30 37 38 for black and
Hispanic children % you know what's
what's with this country why can't we
get our [ __ ] together in poverty its
bunch of kids in a sandbox I think our
leaders not only have to think out of
the box but out of the sandbox that they
put themselves in and start getting this
thing organized and how to do that is is
the issue but but it but they keep
starting with the hardest part which is
how you're gonna pay for it instead of
starting with the easy part like what
should we do and then the pay-fors will
come come out of it but isn't a lot of
the reason why there's a lot of poor
people is because we keep funneling more
money to rich people because the bush
don't take away that's my G life is
getting so much better for rich people I
mean it's just a priorities thing
because we have HD television and Wi-Fi
and what that English guy is sending
people to space it's yeah it's getting
more and more crazy how rich people live
because I think even poor people want
rich they sort of feel represented by
rich people
there was there was pulling on that
about people who are not wealthy who
expect to be oh yeah in within ten years
and it's 50% that's why you can get the
vote against yeah interested cause they
they don't want you're gonna win the
lottery they're gonna they're gonna have
the money next year
the real serving their real danger is
yeah that people who were below the
poverty line when Jackie Kennedy was
making those statements many of them
lived on farms and they could live off
literally off the off the farm now the
farmers don't they're all living in the
city so when you're poor you are
desperately poor and there's no good way
out of it but you know right after that
Lyndon Johnson came into office and he
declared a war on poverty it's been
mocked on the right but the truth is if
you look at the facts it actually worked
and worked rather quickly I mean they
reduced the number of people in poverty
from something like 22 percent down to
something I think it was thirteen
percent in a couple of years I'm not
saying you should just throw money at a
problem but when you give money to poor
people they're less poor yes weird all
right we'll have to continue this
another time thank you folks
nice to the guy
[Applause]